we're the cast of marvel studios loki
and we're going to play a game of hey
loki is this everything that you've ever
said please sign to verify this is
everything you've ever said this is
absurd ready i'm ready it's ready
forever
let's see how you do you were made to be
ruled yes i'm going to say yes correct
our destiny is to rule all others that
is definitely something loki said no it
sounds like loki but i've never said
that i'm only alive because fate wants
me alive yes no
it's thor
i can feel the righteousness surging
that's technically me but it isn't me
it's chris evans but it's low-key
shape-shifted into captain america so
yes
hurts doesn't it mean lied to yes loki i
said that loki said that can i just say
i love the way you're reading these
i'm putting something into it that is
the party plays on the sacred timeline i
feel like that's my line
you know it's a trap right
and
star wars
four oh
i should know that
you could not live with your own failure
say no that's actually something that my
dad might have said that to me
i am loki and i am burdened with
glorious purpose